hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the 2020 chasuble Masters it's
again Magnus Carlsen versus onigiri and
after four games of rapid the score is a
tie and they have to go into blitz
playoffs now the first game of the blitz
section ended in a draw and this is now
the second game of the blade so if this
one also ends in a draw then we go into
Armageddon Magnus
waited the white pieces opens with E for
or does he no he doesn't I'm pretty sure
it's a d4 yeah he opens with d4 and yeah
sure about that he opens with d4 I have
no idea what just happened but before we
check out the actual game Google
released another chest song called
end games the bloody end games I'm sure
you all know which song it is referring
to and the leering lyrics to the song
were written by none other than former
world chess champion Vladimir Kramnik so
do check it out the link will be the
first thing you see in the description
below now getting back to the game after
d4 we have Knight to f6
so Geary replies with Knight to f6 c4 e6
we have nice the c3 and a Giri goes for
the nimzo-indian defense as you always
should with Bishop to b4 Magnus goes a
three immediately challenges the bishop
we have a trade here n c5 we entered the
semi variation of the of the names Oh
III we have Knight to c6 and now Bishop
to d3 just fighting for the e4 square
nicely developing the bishop we have d6
and Knight to e2 now going for or going
for Knight to g3 and now as white
allowed it
Geary immediately strikes in the center
with E 5 he kinda he kind of provokes d5
so he can go efore which would be which
would be very nice because you either
kick the bishop back and get the e5
square for your knight or you get some
nice trades in even even the price of a
pawn for example bunch of characters
Knight captures captures captures and ok
it's not even at the price of a pond but
it would be would be very interesting
but all of blacks problems go away you
don't have to worry about any how to
develop your lights for a bishop or
anything you can go d5 in the future if
you want you have a nice B file for your
rook so everything is nicely set up
so instead of Magnus goes Knight to g3
and now h5 Giri wants to kick it away
with h4 and now there is one game in the
database where d5 was played but here
Magnus was for h4 he prevents h4 by
black and it is as a move tendered we
have a completely new game and now Queen
to e7 the white king is still in the
center so it does make sense to develop
the Queen also maybe some captures on d4
will be possible so here is where Magnus
closes the center with d5 and here he is
a basically challenging giri to go
efore and this this idea does come with
with a pawn sacrifice for example if you
go e for here then for example yeah you
can go bush up to b1 and now after
Knight to e5 yes you've cleared e5
square for the knight but now you have
to give up this pawn and after
characters captures and captures it's
it's a very interesting position for
example to g4 now f3 yes you have to go
back but you know the the white position
is is a bit shaky and you could have a
lot of counter play here with the black
piece as it is it is a blitz game so
here instead Geary went back Knight to
be 8 and this is well we do often say
that the hardest move to find is a move
with the knight back but this is not one
of those positions so here now Magnus
immediately goes e4 he doesn't allow
efore by Erie and now Bishop g4 okay we
have f3 Bishop goes back and now Bishop
to g5 and if you look at blacks position
now you don't really have a good
developing move like where are you
developing the night how is the row
getting into the game where is the
bishop going all of the all of the
squares are taken from the from the
black Bishop like it's not it's not
ideal and what's worse it's a blitz
games you don't have a lot of time to
create some sort of an elaborate plan of
how to develop your pieces so here
Queen to c7 giri immediately on pins and
allows the capture on f6 which Magnus
goes for so we have characters captures
and Magnus just castles he's not afraid
of the open semi-open G file as that
rook is pretty much stuck guarding the
pawn and even if you could like
sacrifice the pawn for some activity
black still has to develop his queen
size to even consider attacking so
Knight studies
and here Magnus doesn't want to give
Gary any any free Tempe at the try and
developed so he strikes with f4 right
away the king is still in the center of
the board so it does make sense we have
each character's an f4 knight characters
on h5 now as now the Queen also guards
the knight and Knight to e5 gira grabs
the e5 square for his knight but now he
also gives up the f6 pawn you could try
and not do this but if you lock
characters in the for the Queen to come
into the game you are losing the f6
point either way so it's not really that
big of a deal so 95 by Gary and now
Knight captures on f6 with check King to
d8 and now rook captures on f4 but now a
Giri goes back with Knight to g6 and now
it attacks the rook and also there's a
double attack on the h4 pawn here saying
that okay if you go back I'm just gonna
capture here and now it's actually not
not all that bad for black he opened up
some files for the attack he's gonna
develop the LightSquared bishop he's
gonna try and get this rook into the
game somehow but well my phone is
listening to what I'm saying that's
that's not cool man
and yeah it would be it would be a good
position for black so instead of moving
back Magnus just goes Knight Queen to f3
he gives up the exchange saying I would
like to keep my pawn on h4 and I want to
mount an attack here along the F file
and Geary says I'm not I'm not touching
that well you could grab it but he
doesn't want to take it and but it's not
all that easy to decline it for example
if you go rook captures on h4 rook
captures and Knight captures just the
Queen to h5 is sufficient here and it's
the knight is under attack the h8 square
is under attack and if you go back
nigera guard both and the h8 square now
there's a 5 coming and just the entire
position just falls apart for black so
Knight characters on e5 is probably what
we would see queen h8 check King e7 and
now let's say rook f1 defending the
knife threatening Quinta e8 checkmate
and well black is out of options here
you could try and defend it with Queen
to d8 but then Queen h4 and all of these
squares are taken
nasty discoveries are coming in black
will fall apart here so it's not easy to
decline the rook by let's say playing
that which we've just shown so here e
declines it with Queen to e7 he still
doesn't want to take it but now Magnus
forces him to take it he pushes h5 and
now there is no good square for the
knight you kinda do have to capture it
so Knight captures we have Queen
captures and now the Queen's guards
denied denied nicely guards the h5 pawn
so Queen e5 offering a queen trade URI
is now up the exchange however the past
H pawn is a past age phone and Magnus
gladly accepts the Queen Sakura at the
Queen trade we have captures captures
and now g4 defending that h5 pass pawn
and also the knight guards the g4 point
so everything is nicely defended and
Geary plays the absolute strongest move
here he goes for a 5 he wants to play
rook to a6 and get the rook in there
game to help out with the defense along
the 6th rank and also there could be
some nasty plans for black as well
so here Magnus goes g5 now the knight is
also nicely defended and rook to a6 and
here is a very very interesting position
even though it's a blitz game for them
but for you you can pause the video of
course so feel free to pause the video
here what do you play here for white
just to give it some give it a think and
try and try and figure it out while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting that you do
not want black to give back the exchange
and for those who if you just wanna
enjoy the show the star move is Bishop
to eat you actually because what you
want to prevent is rook captures on f6
and it's not a difficult move to find
but it's a difficult move to find in in
a way that you have very little time on
the clock when you're actually playing
the game and now you have to calculate
what happens after rook to b6 and do you
want to allow black to infiltrate here
but as you know this is a video so I am
going to show what happens so let's say
rook b6 going for Luke the b3 to go
after some pawns here King F to white
starts bringing the King into the game
now rook b3 and now comes d6 that's the
that's the point threatening d7 and if
Bishop captures rook d1
just attacks the bishop and it's lost
since there will be a double attack now
so black would have to develop and now a
for preparing to move the rook and the
SU you do lose the the c3 rook but now
rugby won and now the rook is coming to
b5 for example King c8 route b5 and now
you are just gonna gobble up all of
these points and we'll have a very nice
game so that's kind of what happens here
after this rook rook takes if Bishop to
e2 is played however you don't have a
lot of time on the clock so Magnus
instead played rugby one first he
doesn't want to allow this rook to come
to b6 and also he wants to just bring
his rook to b5 but now he allows Geary
this well move that really really gets
rid of Carlson's basically a trump card
so here rook captures on f6 just getting
rid of that night we have G captures and
rook captures on h5 so give it gives
back the exchange however he gets rid of
the past H pawn and now again we do have
a game so rook to b5 Magnus now gets
what he wanted here attacks here the a5
pawn and the c5 pawn and now rook to h3
Geary also wants to go after some
weaknesses here we have Bishop back to E
- and now rook captures and c3 Magnus
captures on a5 and now we have rook to
e3 attacking the bishop also threatening
the e4 pawn bishop to h5 n now rook
captures on e4 and now the very
interesting not Bishop captures on f7
but rather rook to e8 with ideas of
captures Bishop e6 going after the
bishop here so here Giri doesn't want to
play something like rook characters on
c4 allowed this and and then have to
deal with this he first goes King to c7
he and pins now the bishop can move but
now again feel free to pause the video
and win this game for Magnus while I
well I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting tactics even
in an endgame and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy show it's d6 check now
you try and get the King away from the
defense of the bishop of course Geary
declines the offer with King D 7 but now
Bishop captures on f7 and it's not not
all that easy for BA
the fine moves so here Gary tried ruby
g4 check King 2 h2 and now rope 2f for
going after df6 pawn here but again
magnus plays the absolute strongest and
the only winning move King to g3 and the
reason why I think the g3 is incredibly
strong because now Bishop to h5 will be
followed by Bishop to g4 the king will
be defending the bishop here and then
it's just game over
so here rook captures on f6 was played
there is nothing better
Bishop to h5 and now rook to f4 again
but it doesn't really matter
yes you do go for the c4 pawn but the
ship the g4 is coming and you don't
really have the option of giving up this
exchange now since black still cannot
move this is just terrible this is this
is a light square bishop you do not want
to have like ever it's just just a big
liability for for the entire game so
after a Bishop to g4 check and Gary
finally gave up this bishop and now we
have Bishop chapters on c8 we have rook
captures on c4 and now Bishop captures
on b7 and now if Gary could get rid of
this 83 pawn he could have some drawing
chances however that's much easier said
than done
so rooks III check King to g4 but the a3
ponies now guarded giving starts pushing
his passed pawn and now Bishop the e4 in
guarding not allowing the King to go
anywhere near blocking this one as well
we have looked the c1 making room for
the pawn to start marching forward but
now rook the a5 preparing rookie for
check maybe a lot of possibilities here
so look at one cutting the white king of
the game King G 3 we have rook to f4
going after the bishop bishop to f3 now
we have looked the d4 and now King f2 of
course the Magnus wants to bring the
King as close as possible rug d3 and now
Bishop the e4 again challenging the rook
rook to b3 and now King to e2 getting
closer into the game rugby to check we
have King to e3 rugby 3 check we have
King to beat you and now King to c7 by
giri but now just a four by Magnus and
now we have King to b6 attacking the
rook but not rook characters on e5
there's not much you can do here
to be for going after Carlson's passed
pawn here but now the shop the c2 by
Magnus and it was in this position
unmoved 54 that uh nigiri resigned the
game and with it the match as this was
game six the game five ended in a draw
so Magnus wins the blood section and
with it the match so we do not get
Armageddon in this match and the Magnus
is the winner of the first match so we
have a second match today which Geary
has to win if he wants the force match
three and we of course are all hoping
for forgiver to win as we do want this
final to go on as long as possible
but yeah here you resigned as it's very
easy to continue king c3 is coming and
after that you just don't have any moves
let's say would be to king c3 and
there's a double attack okay you can go
for okay to guarding the pawn but just
you can go rogue b5 check since the king
cannot capture you have to guard the
bishop here but after the king move just
rook c5 you're gonna capture the pawn
next this is nicely defended and there's
nothing much to look for here so after
Bishop to see - Gary resigns and we
continue today with the second match and
after this
Magnus of course tweeted as you know he
passed the tweet when when he's playing
Geary and it is also the reason why I
chose the title of this video however I
cannot help you
regarding what it actually means Magnus
says the second try some you win some
you lose and he tagged Geary but s o me
is with a capital S and the capital M
however I have no idea what what this
means probably some sort of a clever
joke but I was unable to figure it out
if any of you guys have some insight as
to what what it could be
do share in the comments so you know I
can I can also enjoy what it actually
means but yeah and once again I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to think
that dr. lynskey David Pearce kill
Osterman of emil the daiquiri and at the
daiquiri and the Thomas Conners for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos serie
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the finals of the
2020 testable masters checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and do check
out who a song
link is in the description see you soon
guys